voici le nouveau logo qui avec de la
chance pourrait devenir familier aux
consommateurs martinique et le label 0
chlordécone
les premiers labels ont été délivrés ce
matin huit exploitations parmi lesquels
la ferme solidaire de carrère huit
exploitations du morne-rouge au
saint-esprit vérifié par un expert
indépendant neige chez certaines
pratiques d où des producteurs qui nous
permet de réussir effectivement que ce
qu'elle nous dit correspond à ce qu'il
fait réellement et c'est la base de tout
ça en hongrie en cauchies ces présents
ou passés ces acquis ou pape et à partir
de là on détermine les produits qui
peuvent être labellisés et au clos des
conditions d'exploitation contrôle de la
terre de l'eau d'irrigation du fourrage
pour les animaux
les contraintes sont nombreuses pour
obtenir le label mais cela ne fait pas
peur aux exploitants ils sont plus d'une
centaine à s'être porté candidat
il faut dire que le label est nécessaire
pour rassurer les clients tous les
auscitains côté sa soeur dit qu'elle
décore l'école et je me dis à chaque
fois non autorisée pour s'acquitter
s'invite à la map et pavol va toujours
mal à ses couleurs à ripoll même si
odile nos italies du règne wing je me
suis quand même dit non voilée par
l'étoile et pour l'éloigner label dallas
fondamentaux le monde nous faut des mois
vol pour vibrer faut d'abord tout mon
talent qualité qui parle on déconne et
qu'on nous paie produit c'est moi et toi
tout bobigny faits de vol quand même
beaucoup dans cette histoire nicole à la
manoeuvre le parc naturel et son
président louis boutrin ils bataillent
sur le chlordécone depuis plus de dix
ans la publication récente d'une enquête
sur la fertilité a confirmé le besoin
d'une filière propre
on connaissait les conséquences en
matière de cancer aujourd'hui on voit
qu'il y a des conséquences quant à l'as
père m'a toujours gêné c'est à dire la
production de spermatozoïdes avec une
diminution de la fécondité masculine ce
qui est des cons 10 des conséquences sur
la population globalement c'est
inquiétant c'est grave
donc on peut pas rester là spectateurs
les bras croisés
pour l'heure les produits labellisés
seront vendus sur les exploitations et
dans les mains
chez des communes respectives un
démarrage timide mais si tous les
engagements sont respectés
il devrait même déboucher sur une
filière en grande surface